KAVANAUGH BATTLE.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
"ANGLE."
THE PRESIDENT GAVE REPUBLICANS A
MASTER CLASS IN RETALIATING
AGAINST THE TACTICS OF THE LEFT
TODAY.
UNDOUBTABLY WEARY OF WATCHING
THE DAILY SMEAR STORM BUFFETING
A SUPREME COURT NOMINEE, BRETT
KAVANAUGH, PRESIDENT TRUMP
DECIDED IT WAS TIME TO DO WHAT
HE DOES BEST, FIGHT BACK.
>> THE DEMOCRATS ARE PLAYING A
CON GAME.
A CON GAME.
THEY KNOW IT'S A CON GAME.
THEY KNOW HE'S HIGH QUALITY.
AND THEY WINK AT EACH OTHER.
THEY ARE WINKING.
THEY KNOW IT'S A CON GAME.
>> Laura: DONALD TRUMP IS
NEVER GOING TO BE CONTENT TO
HANG BACK AND PLAY DEFENSE WHEN
HE SEES HIS AGENDA IN JEOPARDY.
HE TRIED THAT A LITTLE BIT A FEW
DAYS LAST WEEK WHEN THIS PIECE
OF AN ALLEGATION WAS DROPPED AND
HE WON PRAISE FOR BEING MEASURED
AND PRESIDENTIAL.
THAT IS NICE BUT MEANWHILE HIS
NOMINEE WAS UNDER MASSIVE
LEFT-WING ASSAULT.
AS REPUBLICANS ON THE COMMITTEE
WERE BENDING OVER BACKWARDS TO
ACCOMMODATE THE ACCUSER'S
DEMANDS FOR DELAYS AND VARIOUS
CONDITIONS.
WELL, TRUMP IS BACK AND NOT A
MOMENT TOO SOON.
>> IS A SHAME THAT YOU CAN DO
THIS TO A PERSON'S LIFE.
I WILL TELL YOU, MAYBE EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT, WHO IS GOING TO WANT
TO GO BEFORE THIS SYSTEM TO BE A
SUPREME COURT JUDGE OR TO BE A
JUDGE OR TO EVEN BE A
POLITICIAN?
>> Laura: THAT'S A GREAT
POINT.
YOU NOTICE HOW HE BOILS IT ALL
DOWN TO A STARK SET OF FACTS?
FACTS THAT CAN BE UNDERSTOOD BY
ALL AMERICANS.
HE'S UNAFRAID -- WHEN EVERYONE
ELSE IS TELLING THEM DON'T DO
IT, DON'T DO IT -- WHEN
NECESSARY, TO COUNTERPUNCH.
>> 36 YEARS AGO, NOBODY EVER
KNEW ABOUT IT, NOBODY EVER HEARD
ABOUT IT, AND NOW A NEW CHARGE
COMES UP, AND SHE SAID, IT MIGHT
NOT BE HIM.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN HIM, MAYBE
NOT.
SHE ADMITS THAT SHE WAS DRUNK.
SHE ADMITS TIME LAPSES.
THERE WERE TIME LAPSES.
>> Laura: AND HE'S TAKING THE
SAME APPROACH ON THE WORLD
STAGE.
AT THE U.N. TODAY, AT THE GLOBAL
ELITES SHIFTED IN THEIR CHAIRS
UNCOMFORTABLY, HE DELIVERED A
FIERCELY PRO-AMERICAN,
PRO-SOVEREIGNTY MESSAGE.
>> WE WILL NEVER SURRENDER
AMERICA'S SOVEREIGNTY TO AN
UNELECTED, UNACCOUNTABLE GLOBAL
BUREAUCRACY.
AMERICA IS GOVERNED BY
AMERICANS.
WE REJECT THE IDEOLOGY OF
GLOBALISM AND WE EMBRACE THE
DOCTRINE OF PATRIOTISM.
>> Laura: HE IS DEFIANT.
HE'S AN APOLOGETIC PARADE CLEAR.
WE NEED MORE, NOT LESS OF THAT
TODAY.
I WANT TO GET BACK TO KAVANAUGH
BECAUSE LAST WEEK WITH TRUMP ON
THE SIDELINES, SENATE
REPUBLICANS WALKED RIGHT INTO
THE TRAP SET BY THE LEFT-WING
SMEAR SQUAD.
SO FOLKS LIKE SENATOR FLAKE,
COLLINS, AND MARKOWSKI, THEY
FELT PRESSURED TO GIVE INTO
THE ME TOO MILITANTS, FORCING
SENATE JUDICIARY CHAIR CHUCK
GRASSLEY TO POSTPONE LAST
THURSDAY'S KAVANAUGH VOTE.
WHEN THE DEMOCRATS, THOUGH, WERE
GIVEN AN END, THEY TOOK A MILE,
AND THEY BEGAN TO SLOWLY TAKE TE
CONFIRMATION PROCESS HOSTAGE.
WHAT DID REPUBLICANS GOOD FOR
ALL OF THEIR COOPERATION AND
SENSITIVITY?
AN EXTENDED, VICIOUS.
>> I'VE HEARD MANY, MANY
PREDATORS SAY AND REFUTE
ALLEGATIONS.
>> SHE HAS NOTHING TO GAIN AND
EVERYTHING TO LOSE, THAT HE WAS
A DRUNKEN, ALMOST RAPIST.
>> THEY ARE WILLING TO PUT
SOMEONE ON THE SUPREME COURT
SOMEONE WHO MAY VERY WELL BE A
PREDATOR.
>> Laura: A MOB LIKE CIRCUS IN
THE HALLWAYS OF THE SENATE
OFFICES, AND TO NOW
ANTI-KAVANAUGH NASTIES ARE
TARGETING AND TRYING TO
HUMILIATE REPUBLICAN SENATORS
WHEN THEY ARE OUT IN PUBLIC.
OPEN [CHANTING "WE BELIEVE
SURVIVORS"]
>> Laura: I THINK MOST
AMERICANS BRISTLE AT THIS STUFF.
THESE UNCIVIL TACTICS AND SLIMY
SPHERES AGAINST GOOD PEOPLE I
THINK ARE EXPOSING JUST HOW
RADICALIZED, HOW CONTEMPTIBLE
SOME STRAINS OF TODAY'S
DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS BECOME.
BUT I THINK THERE IS SOMETHING
POSITIVE THAT HAS EMERGED IN ALL
OF THIS.
REPUBLICANS ARE BEGINNING TO SEE
WHAT THEY ARE CAPABLE OF
ACTUALLY ACCOMPLISHING WHEN THEY
WORK TOGETHER.
WITHOUT THE INTERPARTY FIGHTS,
THE WARFARE, THEY CAN ACTUALLY
DO A GOOD DEAL OF GOOD.
I AM TOLD THAT
PRESIDENT GEORGE W. BUSH IS
MAKING CALLS ON KAVANAUGH'S
BEHALF.
IT WAS VERY ENCOURAGING TO SEE
McCONNELL STAND FIRM.
>> JUSTICE MATTERS.
EVIDENCE MATTERS.
FACTS MATTER.
VAGUE, UNSUBSTANTIATED, AND
UNCORROBORATED ALLEGATIONS OF 30
PLUS-YEAR-OLD MISCONDUCT, WHERE
ALL THE SUPPOSED WITNESSES
EITHER TOTALLY DENY IT CAN'T
CONFIRM IT, IS NOWHERE NEAR
GROUNDS TO NULLIFY SOMEONE'S
CAREER OR DESTROY THEIR GOOD
NAME.
>> Laura: AMEN.
AND IT'S ABOUT TIME ALL
REPUBLICANS CALLED THIS OUT,
WHAT THEY HAVE DONE TO BRETT
KAVANAUGH FOR WHAT IT IS.
IT'S A TOTAL DISGRACE.
BUT THE DEMOCRATS COME OF
COURSE, CONVENIENTLY LOOK THE
OTHER WAY WHEN THEIR HEROES ARE
ACCUSED OF RAPE, ABUSE OF
INTERNS, AND EVEN WHEN THEY
LEAVE A WOMAN TO DIE IN 5 FEET
OF WATER.
BRETT KAVANAUGH, WITH NO
CRIMINAL RECORD, AND NO PATTERN
OF ABUSIVE CONDUCT, MUST BE
DESTROYED AT ALL COST.
A LARGER VIEW MAY NOT KNOW THAT
TEXAS SENATE CANDIDATE BETO
O'ROURKE, THE NEW DARLING OF
THE LEFT, ACTUALLY HAS A
CRIMINAL RECORD, INCLUDING A DWI
A DWI END OF BURGLARY ARREST BUT
NO BIG DEAL.
[LAUGHS]
OKAY.
COME ON.
AT LEAST HE CONDEMNED WHAT
HAPPENED TO TED CRUZ LAST NIGHT.
THAT WAS NICE.
NEGOTIATING WITH TERRORISTS.
WE HEAR THAT IT'S ALWAYS A BAD
IDEA.
ALMOST ALWAYS.
BY DOING SO, WHAT DO YOU GET?
YOU GET MORE TERRORISM.
IT IS GOOD THAT THE G.O.P. HAS
NOT GIVEN INTO THIS RAPID MOB
MENTALITY BECAUSE TO DO SO WOULD
HAVE ONLY EMBOLDENED THE WORST
INSTINCTS OF THE LEFT.
SENATOR GRASSLEY DECISION TO
SCHEDULE THE KAVANAUGH COMMITTEE
VOTE THIS FRIDAY IN THE MORNING
IS ANOTHER POSITIVE DEVELOPMENT
TONIGHT.
IF THE G.O.P. CONTINUES TO FIGHT
FOR FAIRNESS AND JUSTICE IN THE
WAY THAT TRUMP HAS ON ISSUE